you know i went to byu so every downs
are throwing down i mean that's how
that's how that goes you know
i was educated that way by labelle
edwards
throw any time any place and
try to remain keep a little bit of that
with me as i've gone forward
andy reid talking about the decision
yesterday to ice the game with the short
throw to tyree kill who took a seat they
killed the clock and that was that there
was a play earlier in the game though on
third and one where the chiefs called
for a run even though the quarterback
who ran the ball had a bad toe and
ultimately suffered a concussion first
question comes from dean osborne 42 we
tell quarterbacks to be smart get out of
bounds all the time to avoid injury why
does andy reed get a complete media pass
for risking patrick mahomes on plays
like the one he suffered the concussion
on sunday
i
there's always been something different
and special about mahomes in that when
he runs no one ever gets a clean shot at
him we saw it last year in the afc
championship game when he was running
circles around titan's players who
seemed to be afraid of their own shadows
and they didn't want to get close to him
and they didn't want to risk
taking a 15-yard penalty and of course
that sparked some conversation leading
up to the super bowl that got chiefs
fans fired up because i suggested the
49ers players should treat mahomes like
a runner if he's gonna act like a runner
but that's exactly what happened
yesterday when you run the ball there
are going to be defenses who treat you
like a runner and
mac wilson got a clean hit now there is
that question as to whether or not there
was lowering of the helmet to initiate
contact but
it didn't look like a dirty play he was
tackling a runner that's how you tackle
a runner and that's the risk you take
shireen when you have the guy run the
ball and maybe they'll think about that
differently after what happened to
mahomes on sunday
yeah they absolutely might mike and i
had a problem with it just because of
his toe injury you know to me you're
risking a little bit of making that toll
worse
uh and it's obvious he was limping
around on it but this is what they've
done and and it's the playoffs i didn't
question the play call at the time i
mean this is what you do in the play
playoffs you call the plays you think
will work regardless of the
circumstances and
you saw what chad henney did right put
his head down they have no other
quarterbacks i don't think active in
that game but he put his head down and
and tried to get the first down and
thought he had the first down on the on
the long run at the end of that game to
try to run out the time and that's what
you do in the playoffs i mean you throw
caution into the wind and and i think
that's what the chiefs did on that but
i'm with you they have treated patrick
mahomes like this throughout his career
and uh he you know he's been pretty
fortunate and let's face it mike when
you get injured sometimes you're
fortunate sometimes you're not fortunate
to be injured or not be injured in these
games sometimes that's just the way it
goes
yeah luck has a lot to do with it for
the most part we've seen patrick mahomes
put himself in harm's way
and not get hit and not get injured it
was that knee injury that looked really
bad on a thursday night against the
broncos in 2019 he ended up missing a
couple of games henny was injured or he
would have played in those games it was
matt moore instead and did all right and
that's the thing the chiefs can pivot
without mahomes and still have an
effective offense because of the weapons
they have although it's a lot more
effective when mahomes plays the texans
will be a lot more effective if they
have deshawn watson burn unit has this
question if deshaun watson is traded
could you envision the texans trading
him to a team inside the afc i'll take
the first crack at this one this one's
simple
deshaun watson has a no trade clause in
his contract and that doesn't mean he
can't be traded at all it means he can't
be traded without his permission so
before they would trade him they need to
go to him and say give us a list of
teams that you'll play for and we've
already heard plenty of chatter that the
dolphins are a team that he would play
for so i don't know if they would trade
him in the division although i'm
intrigued by the possibility of desean
watson straight up for trevor lawrence
but they'll trade him to the place where
they get the best deal and
uh at least they should trade him to the
place where they get the best deal
although i would shy away if possible
from keeping him in the division and if
you can send me to the nfc shireen but
they're just gonna have to they're gonna
have to get the best deal they can if
they decide to go forward with the trade
and you look at the top of the draft
order mike it's all afc teams so you
start to think well if they're going to
get a top draft pick that's probably
where he's going to have to go you also
look at quarterbacks i mean to me it's
got to be if you're trading deshaun
watson you've got to get a quarterback
for him whether that's a matt stafford
or a carson wentz if you think you're
one with him or a matt ryan or a
tuatanga vala whoever that is i think
you've got to get a quarterback in that
trade as well as picks and a quarterback
that you think possibly that you can win
with
yeah i agree with you completely and uh
look their best bet is to try to fix
this i just don't have faith given what
we've seen from the texans in recent
weeks that they will know how to fix
this they're like in quicksand and the
harder they try to get out the deeper
they are getting all right a couple of
questions here combined tacos and gin
and te genzler 14 as it relates to the
rule that we saw yesterday the worst
rule in football sims and i argued about
that a little bit today we've argued
about it in the past you fumble the ball
short of the goal line the ball goes
into the end zone and goes out of bounds
unrecovered the ball goes to the defense
at it's 20.
tacos and jin asks will they ever change
the fumble end zone touchback rule and
terry gensler suggests that it it
changes from being a touchback to the
ball is it the original spot of the
fumble offense keeps possession and loss
of down i mean that that's what it is if
the ball goes out of bounds at the one
inch line you fumble at the two it
trickles forward it goes out of bounds
at the one inch line it's your ball
still at the two loss of down and we
just go forward um shireen look i
i think that's the only solution if they
would change it and here's my answer as
to when they would change it or how they
would change it or where they would
change it
super bowl sunday
if it happens
in that setting when 130 million or more
people are watching many of whom are
casual fans
many of whom would be very confused and
dismayed as they understand what this
stupid rule is and the outcry that would
come from that especially if it affects
the game if it happens in the second
half and really changes the momentum and
and it ends up being a 10 or a 14 point
swing that's when the nfl will all of a
sudden say oh well we have to change
this even though it's been hiding in
plain sight for years they'll change it
when it embarrasses the nfl
on its biggest day of the year that's
when they'll change it
i think it's enough mike that it
happened in the divisional round in a
one score game that they will at least
talk about it in the offseason but i
also think if it would happen in the
championship game that that they would
change it as well because you look at
the past interference penalty that
wasn't called in the ram saints game and
how it affected that game and they did
go briefly put in instant replay just
off of that play that one play in the
championship game so i do think these
games coming up if it happens again
that'll be enough to get this rule
changed it should be changed however you
change it i don't care how you change it
but the defense shouldn't get the ball
and i'm glad you agree with me here's
the weird dynamic though that applies in
situations like this you would think
that the browns would submit a proposal
in march
for a rule absolutely getting rid of the
rule that screwed them but when a team
gets screwed by a rule like this shireen
they don't want it to go away because
they think in this weird karma
thing that that's going to help them the
next time so they don't want it to go
away because next time around it's going
to benefit them
yeah sure and then it happens again
they just they need to change the rule
mike simple as that they need to it's
been there forever and no one has ever
given me a good explanation why when i
press the nfl it's basically it was like
that when we got here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports